would you eat a hamburger or a chicken
nugget made of meat grown in the
laboratory joshua tarik co-founder and
CEO of just is betting that you will in
tomorrow's world you can eat more meat
hopefully safer even better tasting meat
without eating the animal just which is
based in san francisco has been
producing and selling non animal
versions of food like mayonnaise since
2013 and it's raised more than 310
million dollars in venture capital
Tetrick and his team have created
products like just mayo by identifying
plant-based alternatives to common
animal products like eggs
we're one part pharma one part biotech
and a whole bunch of regular food
company we build a discovery system that
has the only patent in the world that
utilizes machine learning for food
ingredient discovery and it helped us
find this mung bean that when you put it
in the pan scrambles and that process
broken down means we source from over 51
countries in the world we looked at
about 21 different molecular properties
we look to see how that bean functions
is it baked a cake
does it gel in a pan and then we see if
it makes ice cream or butter or
scrambled eggs our process of finding
these new tools is high-tech but what we
find is not high-tech at all the mung
bean has been in the world's food system
for 40 400 years I sure as hell didn't
among mein just is one of a handful of
tech companies working to disrupt the
meat production industry while many of
its competitors are pursuing better
plant-based meat substitutes just is
pushing ahead with so-called clean meat
or lab grown animal tissue that requires
no farming no feeding of livestock and
no slaughterhouses only a single sample
from a single animal duplicated
endlessly just and companies like it are
poised to disrupt the entire livestock
industry but the established players are
turning to the government to protect
their turf the United States Cattlemen's
Association which declined to
participate in this story submitted a
petition still under consideration by
the United States Department of
Agriculture asking that the words meat
and beef exclude any products that are
neither derived
animals nor slaughtered in the
traditional manner the power of the term
is a lot more powerful than people think
especially in the food imagining Tesla
launches a pickup truck but US
Department of Transportation says hold
up Tesla Elon you can't call it a pickup
truck you have to call an electric
mobility transport unit that's not
winning in Alabama even though it might
be fast even though it might have an
amazing amount of horsepower look as a
car is identity but foods identity even
one just is also looking to transcend
the vegan versus carnivore paradigm we
don't allow the term begin to be used in
our company not because we don't believe
in the spirit of it that word ends up
turning off 99% of people the food
system needs to start over little girls
in the second row of a class in Liberia
aren't getting proper nutrients a young
boy grew up in Birmingham Alabama is
accelerating a path to type 2 diabetes
animals are being confined in needless
ways it's contributing to climate change
and I think if we can think differently
about the food system while also
realizing that we can't be so new and so
out there that it doesn't like relate to
the everyday human being we can we can
do a whole lot of good and that's that's
what I want to do this isn't tetrax
first fight with entrenched food
interests just Mayo has been threatened
by the egg board believe this when the
company's first product just a Mayo
appeared on the shelves of major
retailers the American Egg Board went on
the attack it tried and failed to get
Whole Foods to pull the product from its
shelves and hired a network of writers
to trash the product on food review
sites Target pulled just may off its
shelves after receiving an anonymous
letter about food safety but an FDA
investigation later found that the
product was safe and investigators
failed to ever identify the author of
the letter at one point egg board
members even discussed putting out a hit
on Tetrick with one writing that he
should have his old buddies from
Brooklyn pay on the visit the officials
claimed to be joking
I think the email where they discussed
putting a hit out on where the American
Egg Board discusses that was problem
the most surprising me now at the time
we probably had like 1520 people in the
company I really know what the hell I
was doing and all of a sudden the egg
industry has an interest in this little
male product and when bigger more
entrenched folks pay attention yeah
maybe it's validating that you're onto
something whether or not consumers are
ready for lab-grown meat is yet to be
seen and the company landed in hot water
with the SCC in 2016 after being accused
of buying its own products off the
shelves to boost sales figures to raise
more venture capital though the company
claims that was a quality control
measure and no charges resulted from the
investigation but with just products in
more than 20,000 stores and plans to
release lab-grown clean meat onto the
market by the end of the year at a
retail price within 30 percent of that
of traditional meat Tetrick is
optimistic about the future of his
company and the global food system it
was an out-of-body experience to sit
there and eat a chicken but have the
chicken that you're eating running
around in front of you we're working on
chicken nuggets
maybe foie gras I want to focus less on
changing the cultural and societal
perceptions of a word I don't know how
long that's gonna take and more on fiend
as many people as I can every day a
little bit better
[Music]